hey youtubers is Charlie thank you
everyone has many questions for this
week's cora Q&A
good news too I'm next gladdock we had a
couple days because we just found out
about the latest comic it's going to be
coming out
alexi be next year caregivers bird's eye
view not come upon the episodes
starting with questions so number one
resist I think you beer is going to try
and destroy the Banyan Grove tree
in coral somehow have to energy been
herself to become the new centre balance
between the spirit world
in the real world which may re connector
to our past lives
or make her into a kinda bland turtle
figure so
there is a possibility that somehow she
could separate herself from her physical
body like she is now
or can be like a book one situation
where like princes you a she has to give
back the energy that was given to her
our Robert to replace what was lost by
the tree I don't think necessarily that
returning things during one's time would
be balanced though
because there was a lot of class
inequality that time and now we're
staying in the idea of democracy
with president Braco in the United
Republic I do think
don't be like a really sad ending I
don't know if coral died as deeply as
the high possibility
like she could sacrifice ourselves
somehow but I don't think completely
taking away bending is the answer
I would totally lose my shit if she
brought the line turtle's back somehow
as far as we know they've completely
died of I don't think that we ever
really got an answer about what happened
to the one we saw during avatar book for
I was gonna hoping to see that again
during core up so fingers crossed for
line turtles
question number two Emery ass is this
guy based on that opal then in bowl and
taking sick it looks pretty sick yes
yeah like it has all the junk coming and
if it snows
and I think it has something to do with
what's going on between the balance
between spirit world in the real world
up on explain that in the next episode
though
these are kinda want to be between the
spiritual world in the physical world
and we've seen that spiritual
consequences though that because bit
wild going crazy like that
find taking people I think this guy
bison getting sick
is that manifesting in the real world
there's no way they would make it look
at sick but that big a runny nose
without something really really being
wrong
question number three lupita ass its
core able to lob end as well
do you think anyone is gonna die before
the show ends be questions
okay so
core yes corrigan do any type a bending
she just has to learn the technique
as for people dying I would say if
there's a good chance that people die it
would be
original avatar characters as well as
core herself the interesting thing about
cora metal bending in like doing all the
sub styles is that
israel is the matter for putting in the
homework as we've seen homework
not really her strong suit like it was
really hard for to learn how to airband
it's very much like a metaphysical pink
so it required
court to go to this really mental place
and all the things that have been
really messed up with her in the last
four books her head has been the most
messed up
if her disconnection from robert is any
example and even a minor mental block
Anna to completely cut her off from her
bending abilities
and we really think about it energy
bending should be the most difficult
style
hehe seems to have a pretty the time
energy bending the reason explain that
she didn't do whenever she was buying
two beers because uses
trying to choose the rational Pat
question number four Cameron ass
why do you think that see here didn't
try to use air bending while he was in
Chains
I would say the Pride's me the chains
too strong for him to break
just from our logic standpoint you know
without trying to over analyze things
too much
they wanted the here to be stuck in
prison so whatever
the story required for him to be stuck
in there take they would have invented
that I guess the explanation
and he's such a special person he lost
believe that
now he's prolly just super Zen all the
time like he paid to spend as much time
as possible
inside the spirit world so his physical
body doesn't matter quite so much
although to be fair he cannot bend in
the spirit world whereas Couric and
as we were now at issue a significant
reversal on Canon
or maybe you can look at it from the
perspective that then just not fully
explaining it before
that was an interesting thing to week
it's been like a whole other video
talking about
you know the way they explain the logic
they haven't pulled the rug out from
under us
too much but when you think about it
it's possible for some these characters
to be
unreliable narrators maybe even an
avatar by Corzine avatar so
if she has a misconception about
something exploded someone else
then will get the wrong idea about it
because you can automatically assume the
Avatar knows everything
especially if it's one in the past lives
with me the older avatars like Avatar
Roku
it would be interesting to see the here
let out that prison I mean he is very
powerful
I think that if anyone was gonna die
finale that was not cora it would be
someone that the here killed
and I think you be did let him out he
would actually just got your career at
regular
down it should be a pretty badass fight
to europe purses the year
question for five team as do you think
that toppled by coop Europe for taking
spirit Bynes
and it'll be some sort of conflict I
meet up what's up in a teaser so clearly
they're going to have some sort a battle
between
the bay font-family: interviewers army I
think what we see is top
take out like a large section other army
she so powerful
I mean she is like a club babe on would
be more like the night
which is not quite as powerful as tops
she would probably be the one to run in
top lip I be like their linebacker makes
you just run
at the defense so that it distracted
everyone in the rest them could slip in
and still the family
so easy anything from top I think it
will be like some giant distraction
is awesome is it would be to see her
fight could be read directly
any more personal to see SouFun by could
be right so if anyone actually bytes
computer directly I think it'll be
Syrian
she's kinda like Syrians daughter to
wait so it's much more cats in the
cradle
question for six PC guy ass what about a
sign his father he's a genius to
as in you talking about helping back to
the era yes I do think I'll give them
some advice from inside prison
I don't think the let him out like us up
to serve his sentence out I do think
I'll help
we've only seen a little bit from Assam
his father but I think the help I
provide like some small technical advice
to help them solve the problem
assigning a very might hit a wall like
with observe a question or some sorta
device
and he'll just provide the solution to
that I said it before but I think it is
going to be a more advanced version of
what perry did whenever they were
escaping the Earth Kingdom
good jane EMP something to take out
their entire army at the same time
his career has a shitload a max the
other really cool solution
would be like them badass chain
lightning I'm gonna go ahead and guess
that all those makes are not made out of
non conductive metal
although I would not be surprised if
they did have a little bit a platinum
this is a defense mechanism against
other metal benders question 7
full time slacker ass if he has all the
political power
what exactly does you could do anymore
besides be a reference to last airbender
bats harsh am no as .ico is more of a
White Lotus figure now
it when is the white lawyers business I
mean I'm mostly talking
out spiritual matters like big big world
problems
that don't necessarily just involve the
Fire Nation
I think he's on the same path as I row
he's not going to spiritual as ira was
though
like not quite as why the at be briefly
saw him during the earth Kings
coronation he didn't have any speaking
lines but hopefully he comes back with
the Dragon with rock
I would like you like to see some dragon
eggs with into the series but they might
say that for the comics
question 8 just gas what do you think
this bid bonds are trying to do to the
people that they took
but with the spare part things I'm
actually getting there was all a
mechanism to get
court to fix yourself I'm sure they'll
explain it better whenever
the DVD commentary is released a few
make it brighter with record TV
commentaries and explain everything in
really great detail
but I'm guessing its peers did it as a
big call to action to cora
like it was all about cora otherwise
they would have taken
a lot of people there is more chance
that they were somehow
feeding on the energy inside people it's
such a weird being bit I do think that
they'll explain it in the next couple
episodes though
like it seems like too big a bad thing
to just brush over question 9
a cautious what happened to Julian she
still working on that big weapon with
the Tar junior
I think by the time we see could be
regained back in the swamp like
not with the vision like actually see
her there the weapon will be done so
that's when we'll see Julie again
I'm hoping to get the more context more
lines summer that spell out with the
night she really did turn on Varick
or she's running some sorta inside job
she went from
almost making out with him big-time to
like hard-core hating him
within an episode as I feel like that's
too quick overturned for it to be
completely genuine
I feel like he's running some sorta long
con on could be right
questioner 10 Corey as if you can hang
out with any lead in the core character
who would it be
I guess it would depend on what I was
trying to do you know if I had enough
coffee like
if I was caffeinated out early hamlet
bowl and otherwise he would
totally drained all my energy otherwise
I would say no BBS on me as I feels like
one of the more interesting characters
now
does that justify my pic you know yet
Korea is the most powerful character
she's super cool but think about it this
way the Avatar
is like completely disconnected from pop
culture and
if you wanted to hang out with someone
you play talk about Mike
what was going on in the world things
recall like cool bands cool games
core is completely disconnected from
that right now she did out to lunch for
like three years
so cheap would not really had that many
interesting things to say
now if you wanted to say work out but
she be amazing makes you been awesome
workout partner
but if you just wanted to chill out
Asami is private smartest character on
the show
thank you so much everyone purse many
questions is always had a thing to do
remember okay really important date
december nineteenth two-part finale
omitted a different date on when my
other videos but it's basically like
a new episode every week you know or
basically episode 10
and then week after that episode 11 and
then two episodes
it the same time every season they
always the two episodes at the very end
so the be a couple more weeks a regular
bonus videos be sure to subscribe to get
everything
which she reminds me congratulations to
this week's giveaway winner
gear Williams you in the Amazon gift
card just visit me on my channel for
details you miss me when it when our
Amazon gift card
so again just quick reminder on the
comic book coming up
September 23rd 2013 I know that's a long
ways away the senate already talked
about the next couple
comics big became an idea about what
kinda stories they want to do
but it just means that there will be
more Dark Horse Comics
so whenever does roll around to next
year that first smokin shadow comical
bisbee part 1
part 1 of 3 so everybody breathe easy
not only do out separate bonus video
about it
they did not say anything about alleging
the core comic but
to spy on a table it is bro quick
reminder new mobile links appear for
your mobile phone or on your tablet or
somewhere else he could on this is the
same as the links over here
but me now secure per episode 9 video in
click here for me episode a video thank
you so much watching sort of halfpipe
I will see you guys tonight